sono vincenzo 36 anni e sono nato qua
anche se ho passato la maggior parte
della mia vita da adulto altrove
ho studiato in tre paesi ho lavorato in
sei e ho dovuto viaggiare in 61 paesi
dovuto perché pensate finanche mio
perché viaggia per conoscere cose nuove
per provare cibi differenti per andare
in posti caldi quando freddo o posti
freddi quando fa caldo
beh io viaggio per una ragione molto
distinta sapete io sono sono
appassionato avanti sul proprio malato
di caffè ma non di un caffé qualsiasi ma
del caffè che fa la mia caffettiera il
problema di questa di questa caffettiera
è che una caffettiera a cui piace piace
viaggiare e sapete condividere la
cassettiera con lei significa che a un
certo punto della mia vita mi trovo
posti che normalmente le persone solo
vedano per televisione e stasera
parleremo di three biaggi che sono
successi proprio grazie alla caffettiera
il primo viaggio comincia un ottobre del
mi svegliai a va in cucina come ogni
giorno e al posto della caffettiera
trovai questa fotografia ma le conoscete
non la caffettiera per la grande
muraglia indietro era in cina non c'era
un momento da perdere quindi mi misi
andai di corsa alla stazione e mi misi
sul primo treno che andava personaggi
il viaggio mi avrebbe portato attraverso
la russia e la mongolia fino a pechino
avrei fatto in tutto questo viaggio
circa avrei potuto fare in circa 12
giorni percorrendo 11.000 chilometri e
passando attraverso sette funzionari
avrei fatto quello che forse già lo
avrete capito e il transiberiano questo
treno vedete per me che sono figlio di
ferroviere che sono passato dalle
quello zampe direttamente al treno era
era una cosa mitica una di quelle cose
che vuoi raccontare ai nipotini
eppure per le persone che si conoscono
come per esempio andrei andrei che stava
viaggiando con la moglie andrei si stava
spostando da da arcangelo un'asta
sull'artico fino a crash noi a questo è
un viaggio che normalmente si può fare
in tre giorni lui avrebbe fatto per
stare poi sei giorni con i suoi
familiari e poi avrebbe viaggiato per
altri tre giorni il potere della
famiglia anche in russia
pensate che andrei comunque una persona
molto e street a lui normalmente parlava
tre lingue e quando aveva la brillante
idea di aprire la vodka diventavano 5
ovviamente io non parla russo tranne nei
momento di della vodka ovviamente nel
quale conversavo di tante cose con
andrei ma ovviamente dimenticavamo
dimenticavo tutto è così come tra un
brindisi e un altro riuscì a
attraversare della mongolia riuscì a
attraversare tutta la cina è finalmente
arrivato a piazza tienamen provide a mia
amata caffettiera la seconda storia
quale cominciò in una forma molto simile
alla prima però questa volta invece
della foto in in cina c'era la foto di
questa città di dylan che si chiama gli
spara la stessa storia
mi sveglio trova una foto corro alla
stazione però questa volta salgo su un
pullman che mi porta a bari prende una
barca che riporta a sarajevo
gli faccio il visto e poi li tra autobus
treni o qualsiasi mezzo disponibile
attraverso la serbia attraverso la
bulgaria
la turchia è finalmente arrivò l'iran
esattamente a chirac
adesso non si è mai capitato di
viaggiare da soli per lungo tempo ma una
cosa bella è che si conoscono tante
persone nuovamente tanti viaggiatori che
poi viaggiano viaggiano da soli
e in questo questa volta mi capita di
conoscere ora un ragazzo un ragazzo
olandese
insomma piangiamo un po pareggiamo un
pollaio e un giorno mi disse in sé ma io
domani vado sulla montagna davanti a voi
venite con me e me lo disse con una tale
naturalezza che pensa amava sarà un
parco sarà andiamo alba ci facciamo una
camminata e vabbè vola l'unica cosa però
assicuriamoci di avere un posto per
dormire dalle la del rifugio e lui mi
dice che è fuori da cuore da warren
telefoniamo un telefono che pensavamo
essere il rifugio eppure la ci dicono
pawar di novoli no war
quindi noi tranquillamente ci mettiamo
in viaggio e andiamo verso nord e quando
abbiamo perso road
arriviamo a teheran e andiamo a dormire
a casa di alì alì non sapevamo chi fosse
erratico un amico di un amico di olaf e
lucia corsa a casa sua e ali la sera
prima di andare a dormire disse maraga
state a teheran di fare una cosa che
solo quasi può fare che il dr
torna che cos'è il board ore ci si mette
in macchina e si arriva una parte della
città dove le altre macchine girano in
circolo quindi ci si mette in circolo
con le altre macchine e delle altre
macchine ci stanno magari delle altre
ragazze
quindi comincia tutto il gioco così di
sguardi di ammiccamenti e se c'è feeling
le macchine si fermano e poi ci si
scambiano belli telefono e poi potete
immaginare quello che succede nel caso
nostro non avevamo la macchina economica
avevamo vestiti insomma quelli che
avevamo economici e quindi per essere
notati andiamo a casa
prendemmo la chitarra e ci mettiamo a
suonare in macchina immaginate nelle
strade di teheran
potete immaginare l'esito non quello che
sta immaginando alla fine torniamo a
casa tutti e quattro così come eravamo
usciti però
posso dire che abbiamo portato la bamba
in iran quindi insomma andammo a casa a
dormire tutti allegri ma sempre soli è
ripartito il giorno dopo ripartimmo il
giorno dopo è l'obiettivo era arrivare
al primo rifugio 4.200 metri su questa
famosa dama vari ma continue cominciamo
alla resa e subito ci accorgemmo che la
super attrezzatura tecnica che noi
pensavamo di avere in realtà non era
buona avevamo freddo però comunque però
comunque domandavamo in qualche maniera
arrivammo a questo primo rifugio
andammo così tutti contenti dal
responsabile della barra anche gli
dicevo vincenzo la italian dai booking
ultimo ci guarda e dice di no booking e
lo guardiamo e lui ci fa il segno di
andare su per cui andiamo su e vediamo
queste due tavolate così di di legno
tutt'attorno su quei livelli
quelli erano eletti erano praticamente
due letti collettivi e batteri c'erano
tipo gli zaini e le cose dei vari
scalatori comunque cercato di dormire
perché ovviamente eravamo stanchissimi
normalmente sapete se sei stanco già sai
la maggior parte delle cose di cui ha
bisogno per dormire però era un problema
perché la gente si avvicinava a noi e
volevano parlare in inglese perché
allora era una novità vedere due passi
che stavano la quindi la gente veniva
funzioneremo se non è quindi alla fine
abbiamo creato almeno una ventina di
persone di milan che parlano inglese con
accento napoletano però va bene così
comunque restiamo lì più o meno fine
alle 6 alle 16 alzammo e cominciamo a
dare su andare su andare su e vi
assicuro che era una cosa difficilissima
cioè non si può pensare in meno di
ventiquattr'ore scalare 5000 metri non
lo fa della gara però noi lo facemmo lo
facemmo ed eravamo motivati da un
qualcosa che non so che cos'era
anzi lo so io ho fatto pure la foto ed
era questo e noi andavamo su quando
andavamo sospinti dalla motivazione che
rompeva con i nostri limiti fisici
comunque io arrivai fino a 5200 ora fare
qua 5600
molto più giovane ovviamente e decidemmo
di vedere il ciad rifugio dovevamo
passata la notte precedente privati a
rifugio eravamo stremati e non volevamo
passare un'altra coppia su queste tavole
di legno però scendere giungerebbe stata
una mazzata non sapendo che fare insomma
mi affaccio alla finestra del balconcino
che veda la nostra salvezza
un asino non ci critico chi ha molti
potenti degli asili e di game my friends
ha un tipo che parlava inglese peggio di
me dice tipo dice sì ok perfetto chiamò
la viola
visualizza in carico tutto sul
sull'asino e scendiamo giù che arriviamo
a questo posto paghiamo i nostri liberi
2 euro
stiamo per cercare un taxi e viene uno
di questi tipi con un fucile in mano gli
zaini riporta e non è tipo da youtube ei
dovete parlare dovete pagare e noi ci
troviamo a parlare con il capo di questa
persona e lo disse no ragazzi voi ve ne
andate separate 15 euro ciascuno ora si
arrabbiò perché disse sempre la stessa
storia qua ci dicono un prezzo però poi
ce ne vogliono popolare a propagare un
altro insomma si stava scatenando una
crisi diplomatica alla sulle montagne di
line ea un certo punto non c'erano
margini di trattativa perché comunque
questa persona sulla montagna
noi stavamo mettendo in dubbio in dubbio
la sua la sua capacità la sua la sua
forza è suo il suo ruolo come capo
quindi o la ferrari abbia taciuto punto
val dolo etico si entra ma che voi fa e
lui mi dice poi andare a casa lo pensai
casa quando fa freddo quando
l'incertezza è totale quando hai fame
oppure quel pezzettino di pavimento del
soggiorno di uno sconosciuto diventa
casa
fatto sta che andai dal capo di queste
persone ben sapendo che se avessi
parlato di soldi non andava da nessuna
parte e gli dissi con la mano sul cuore
lo so che tu sei un brav'uomo posso
sedermi
e parlammo della sua famiglia la mia
famiglia la sua bambina mia famiglia ed
adattate a ta ta ta ta ta e alla fine 20
euro e ci lasciò andare tranquillamente
a teheran
la terza storia successe giusto dopo che
con la caffettiera avevamo visitato il
taj mahal in india e vorrei farmi
pensare un attimo una cosa pensate a
tutto quello che poi fate i vostri piedi
le vostre gambe le vostre braccia delle
vostre mani e pensate che domani viene
qualcuno è bene tajani perché così fate
più bene perché così
raccogliete più elemosina questo è
quello che successe a un bambino che
avevo conosciuto gli ha già i pur vicino
al taj mahal e un bambino che mi dissero
essere figlio di emigrati e la resa e ma
dopo una mia essere immigrato a volte
può essere molto complicato molto
doloroso tanto la in india come pure
succede ci arriva soprattutto in europa
per esempio alle persone che nel 1884 si
imbarcarono sul matteo braccio una nave
per andare in uruguay lame sovraccarica
e un certo punto e mezzo all'oceano
scoppiarono casi di colera
lì a bordo pensate voi terribile
situazione delta la cosa può ancora
ancora peggiore perché quando arrivavano
al porto di montevideo con accolti con
caro nate e chiaro che le generazioni
anteriori quando quando emigravano
insomma era una cosa molto complicata
molto pericoloso che ha azionato
lunghissimi carissimi e non sapevi mai
domi andare a finire
eppure una volta arrivati a destinazione
era complicato a mettersi in contatto
con la pace perché saranno le lettere
l'altro invece pensate per le
generazioni attuali quanto facile per
esempio viaggiare oggi viaggi con i
soldi che guadagna in un giorno
videotelefoni senza nemmeno pagare più
di due personalmente ho abitato abitato
fuori per tanto tanto tanto tempo e non
mi sono mai sentito come un emigrato ma
piuttosto come quello che porta in giro
il proprio corpo ma il cuore ho sempre
lasciato acqua e giusto tre mesi fa ho
lasciato il lavoro il lavoro che lancerà
a londra e sono tornato qua
e vi dico per viaggiare sempre stato
come una forma di scavare nella della
mia anima e scavando scavando in fondo
ho trovato che tesoro è proprio la terra
da cui provengo e se la terra da cui
proviene che ha tanti problemi e tu puoi
fare qualcosa per risolverli tornare a
casa e la cosa più bella che ti possa
fare grazie